so the way I see my airplane the
technologies are already there if I
could just solve landing and takeoff
that would be a flying car that I would
bet my life on you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
[Music]
autonomous flying agents or flying
robots may seem like the stuff of sci-fi
to the average person but to dr. Rajesh
Kapoor principal researcher and research
manager of the aerial informatics and
robotics group of Microsoft Research
they're much closer to science than to
fiction and having built and flight
tested his own airplane complete with
state-of-the-art avionics designed to
run AI and ml algorithms he has the
street cred or should we say flight cred
to prove it today dr. Kapoor talks about
how cutting-edge machine learning
techniques are empowering a new
generation of autonomous vehicles and
tells us all about air sim an innovative
platform that's helping bridge the
simulator to reality gap paving the way
for safer more robust real-world AI
systems of all kinds that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast Ashish Kapur welcome to
the podcast yeah thank you I'm excited
to be here great to have you you're a
principal researcher and the research
manager of the aerial informatics and
robotics group at MSR give us a picture
in broad brushstrokes generally of what
your group does our group focuses on
robotic agents and more specifically
flying robotic agents that can
positively influence the society so we
are focusing on how the current advances
in robotics machine learning and AI can
help us enable that so talk about this
phrase aerial informatics and robotics
also known by the acronym air yeah I'm
just delightful it's a group and is also
a platform yes yes initely tell us about
that so when we started a few years ago
trying to build these agents this is an
incredibly difficult area to work on and
one of the reasons is the amount of
effort that you need to make sure that
the robotic systems work well in the
environment is huge you are not just
dealing with software you're dealing
with hardware you're dealing with
hardware and software integration you
are dealing with a field study that you
need to make sure that all your robotic
components all your software components
all your hardware component all the
sensor components work well you need to
make sure that in presence of external
environments such as exogenous variables
such as rain when and you know maybe
other human users nearby animals birds
so the amount of progress was very tiny
compared to the amount of time that we
were spending on it and we quickly
realized that what we need to do is we
need to come up with a simulation
platform that would let us recreate
these elements in the lab setting so
that our end-to-end cycle between
development and testing gets reduced
rapidly so consequently we build this
platform a simulation platform and we
released it under the name of Al
informatics and robotics platform so
that's the platform that's the platform
and what it is it's similar
for I to build autonomous agents and
train machine learning systems it's an
AI simulation that's how I think about
it so group is here informatics and
robotics platform and it is really about
flying robots you know and they are
powered by a machine learning they are
powered by AI techniques they are
powered by intelligent human-in-the-loop
methods so we constantly think about how
easy would it be for a pilot to actually
fly these drones and carry out missions
which might be risky which might be
ambitious yeah but at the core of this
group lies this philosophy behind
simulation we think that simulation is
one of the foundational pillars that
would enable us to build these kinds of
technologies right a simulation like
this allows us to rapidly build
prototype and test out our technologies
but it also allows us to make sure that
we make the mistakes in the safety of
our labs it allows us to make sure that
our software's the bugs have been ironed
out before we go and fly the real thing
out in the world when I think about
flying robots it usually has somebody
behind the controls right and so you
talk about humans in the loop
yeah and that they're always going to be
there but yet it seems like you're
moving towards a more and more
autonomous flying robot yeah yeah how is
that different from autopilot today I
would claim that you know there already
been flying robots for a while and your
you know commercial airliners it's a
giant flying robot in fact most of the
flight is actually carried by an
autopilot these days and we are
comfortable with the technology and of
course as human the loop they are pilots
Manning the cockpit and they are making
sure that things are correctly set up
for instance so what has actually
changed is in the recent past all these
technologies are now available for
drones as well so it's exactly the same
technology it's pretty much the path
following but when we think in the
context of drones and you know gliders
and other objects that everyday people
can just go and fly you know the stakes
becomes much higher because now you're
closer to ground there are other people
in the vicinity and they are buildings
there are trees
and the potential for anyone to just
pick it up off the shelf and go and fly
I mean the risks are huge yeah so
consequently we need to start thinking a
little bit more about safety about how
these air technologies can positively
influence our world but also be safe
while doing so tell us about the flight
of your ai-controlled autonomous
infinite soaring machine that you did
last summer I watched the video it was
really cool what was that about and why
is it important that we have these
autonomous infinite soaring machines
gliders that project this was more of an
AI aspirational project and if you think
about some of the recent breakthroughs
in air they have things like
reinforcement learning deep
reinforcement learning or deep machine
learning algorithms but much of this
breakthrough has happened in the
software space when an agent needs to
make a next move they don't have to
worry about the exogenous variables etc
and the second thing is because it's the
inherent software nature of these
problems it's possible to potentially
generate near infinite amount of data
and that's what many of these techniques
are banking on so we started thinking
about what would it take us to actually
think about similar problems but in the
domain of real world AI and this
autonomous glider is basically if you
think about it it's kind of a you know
again but you are playing this game in a
real world so the whole goal in the
autonomous Collider project was to
design an autonomous flying agent that
can travel large distances or that can
stay in the air for long amount of time
and the way it does it it has some
information about the terrain some
information about the weather it has
some statistical model of how the rising
air bubble work and it exploits all this
information in order to make a decision
whether it should hang out at a place
and wait for a rising air to carry it up
and gain altitude or it should go to
another place and while in in doing so
it needs to trade-off between how high
it's flying and how far and what's the
probability of finding such a bubble of
rising air and by doing such kind of
kraid offs it's possible to keep the
glider a lot for a long amount of times
how
this is now a real-world problem we
don't have the luxury of obtaining near
in finite data and in addition we have
to deal with exogenous variables
possibly variables that we have never
accounted for in our algorithms so if we
could solve this problem this will
definitely be a big step in the
development of AI and ml techniques so
the glider doesn't have an engine you
send it off and then what it's doing and
learning is how to stay aloft for a long
period of time without any external
force other than nature the nature
exactly so the glider doesn't have any
external propulsion system all it relies
on is these bubbles of rising air that
it hopes to piggyback upon to get an
altitude and then really the decision
that the glider has to make is where to
go in order to attain the maximum lift
but also such that it doesn't veer too
far away from its core mission yeah so
it's a trade-off between exploration and
exploitation that we talked about in
machine learning
[Music]
well let's talk about the role of
simulation in AI for a bit do you refer
to this as high fidelity simulation to
enable real-world AI and you even said
it represents the next generation of
machine learning models so how and why
is simulation important to your work
into the larger field of AI you know as
you mentioned high fidelity simulation I
think is going to be one of the most
critical component of delivering
real-world AI systems let me tell you
the top two reasons right so the first
reason is that if you look at the you
know recent advances in machine learning
in air these advances are very data
heavy hmm we have spent billions of
dollars in thinking about compute
architecture we have looked into
advances in algorithms and all to make
machine learning systems fast but a
critical component to any of the efforts
is the existence of data if there is no
data none of this is going to matter
right now data is really the bottleneck
you have many startups
you know many labs trying to just
annotate and label the data for you so
that you can build richer and richer
models so the scarcity of the data is
one of the core reasons that simulations
are going to become important and
important so that's the first reason
the second reason is that if you look at
you know recent advances is green
enforcement learning algorithms so any
of the games any of the arcade games
those are perfect simulation to the
situation's your agent will be playing
in and they bank upon it to get more and
more data to gather more and more
experiences and build richer and richer
and better models however in order to
utilize similar techniques for building
real-world air systems we would need
similar kind of simulation and there
doesn't exist a simulator that would
mimic the real world let's talk about
that creating reality in software which
is basically what simulation is right
you're using software to bring a real
world into play and you said that
machine learning simulation models are
like video games on steroids yes what do
you mean by at and what role does
reinforcement learning play in that yes
so you know when I think about
simulation especially simulation to
train AI and ml agents I think about
it's a video game yeah and as I says the
video game on steroids and video game on
steroids that's played not by a person
but by a software a machine learning and
AI agent that expects to explore and
learn from those experience and build
better machine learning models mm-hmm
and in fact if you look at the recent
work in reinforcement learning in deep
reinforcement learning for instance they
are actually playing games they are
playing Atari games they are playing
pacman and they are going to play it on
and on for millions of times and get a
lot of data and get better at it so
imagine if we could create a video game
which is you know mimicking reality in
many different aspects that we wish to
deploy our AI nml systems in and we let
these software agents play on and on and
another valuable experience see all the
corner cases we can expect that these
agents will start to get better
ben'll better machine learning models
which then can be deployed in real world
this is not your average video game the
simulation is a game where we are not
only simulating the virtual world and
the character but we are also simulating
each and every sensor that your
autonomous agent is going to see all of
them are being simulated to a detail
such that the kind of data that your
videogame is providing is very similar
to the real world so consequently if you
train a system end to end in simulation
you can expect that a lot of that
knowledge will be transferred to the
real world
so yeah I'm reinforce but learning is a
very interesting technology and you know
if you think about it how would you take
a reinforcement learning algorithm and
maybe train a car or a drone to fly with
it you know naive application to that
technology in real world is going to be
disastrous
why because if your car makes an error
very likely it's going to be a costly
mistake just to give you a statistic so
for instance if you look at any of the
you know reinforcement learning games
that have been played and that have been
successful the amount of data that has
been pushed through the system is
incredible so for instance for you know
something like pac-man you are looking
at hundreds of millions of frames before
your agent starts to do something that's
reasonable and you know like hundred
million frames at 30 frames per second
is more than a month of compute that's
needed that's going to be expensive for
real-world tasks so consequently if you
had an access to simulation where these
mistakes didn't cost you anything
except for the compute cycle maybe your
learning would be very efficient so all
of these advances in deep reinforcement
learning would be you know very tangible
for the real world applications if there
exists a simulator that could mimic the
real-world behaviors of the vehicles as
well as the consequence of all the
actions those vehicles would take you
know when they are out there tell me a
little bit more about air sim and what
it's doing to bridge the simulation to
reality gap and why do researchers need
to stress test their algorithms so as I
mentioned right the air sim was really a
byproduct of our efforts in building
real-world robotic systems and you know
we quickly realized that in order to be
efficient we need to come up with a
simulation platform that mimics reality
as closely as possible so we embarked on
a journey to build a simulation platform
that's near realistic but also caters to
the problems in the domain of AI but the
thing is there exist nose or the
simulator that can mimic behaviors of AI
systems and that's what else um aspires
to be it says that if your goal is to
train a real-world AI system let's build
components so things like actuators the
worlds the trees the pedestrians other
exogenously abel's like wind all the
sensors you might employ magno meter
barometer extra meter gyroscopes cameras
let's simulate everything in detail as
much as you can and then you can
simulate the entire
ái system end-to-end from collection of
training data to actual deployment
validation and testing we will try to
make the simulation as close to reality
as possible so that when you deployed in
the real world a lot of the learnings in
the simulation world gets transferred
this is what Aramis it aspires to be a
simulator for solving hard a AI and ml
tasks for real world that's so important
for multiple reasons because when I hear
the word Air sim I think of like an
airline simulator right just you get in
a cockpit yeah that's not what it's
about you know it started as a simulator
for aerial robots this is an open-source
project and as soon as we open sourced
we started to get a lot of requests to
extend it to other domains such as you
know automobiles and you know other
scenarios such as farming warehouses etc
right so given that the foundation of
air sim was really about thing about AI
and machine learning system it didn't
take much effort for us to extend it and
open it to other possible AI
applications so right now air SEM is not
just limited to aerial robots in fact it
has a very rich model of ground
automobiles it has ability for you to
create vehicles and robots of your
choice you know we have constructs we
have extensibility build into air sim so
that you can design your own robots
equip them with the sensors that you
prefer so things like multiple cameras
multiple gyroscopes you can place them
on the chassis as you wish and then let
them go in the air some you can even
create different worlds with airs and we
also release a bunch of precompiled
environment binaries which include
cities neighborhoods Suburbans African
savanna mountainous environments and
many other such examples where you can
deploy a robot and see how they interact
how about snow on the freeway yes we can
do that as well we have at least one
environment where you know your car you
can basically drive off-road and it's
mountainous and has all those problems
with unpaved roads etc and that's one of
the advantages of simulation so for
instance what we could do is we could
not only simulate cities and behaviors
of your vehicle we
can actually simulate time of day we can
simulate whether it's raining how much
is it raining whether it's snowing all
of this can be simulated and that leads
to much more richer experience for a
vehicle yeah in a simulation then
possibly in the real world so you know
at the lower level these problems have
been looked for a long long time you
know your brake assist your Park Assist
these are the things that are already in
a pretty you know mature stage of
production however what's lacking is the
decision-making ability right so things
like you know how do I expect the other
car to drive if I am at a stop sign when
should I go if I see a pedestrian you
know at a certain distance how should I
act so all of these higher-level
decision-making tasks are the hard ones
that humans right now are doing and
that's where most of the car technology
lacks so what else I'm a spy has to be
it aspires to be a platform where you
can try and train and test and validate
those high-level decision-making tasks
[Music]
so let's talk about safety in AI systems
what are you doing to tackle this
uncertainty problem in the open world
you know as I mentioned earlier any of
our robots autonomous cars or flying
systems or any IOT device that's AI
enabled will have certain kind of a
perception system and it's never going
to be foolproof there will always be
exogenously Able's that we have not
modeled so there will be cases in which
it's going to make mistake so
consequently the challenge is how do you
then come up with strategies or
algorithms that would work safely
despite knowing that their perception
system might sometimes fail right one of
the key insights that we are banking on
is that if we can build a machine
learning system that has an
understanding of when it's working
correctly versus when it's going to make
a mistake we can then come up with a
strategy that's safe
so it's akin to say a flying robot that
decides to fly fast when it's confident
about its surrounding but when it can't
see things when you know when it's
raining when it's hazy it decides to
slow down in order to think more so we
are investigating strategies such as
that where we embed machine learning
systems that are aware of when they are
working well versus when they are going
to make mistakes and again you know at
the core of all this is actually
simulation if you'd like to think about
a brain of an AI agent we simulate all
different possibilities that we think
are plausible given what the agent has
seen in the world and after running many
of these simulations we then make a
choice between taking a decision that
might be aggressive versus something
that will keep us safe
and we see that in our own lives humans
do that every day
yes caution when I'm afraid yes and of
course you know you imagine things on
you know how things will be if you think
about our imagination is a simulation
portal where we can reason about how
things might be if we took certain
actions and you want our machine
learning and air agents to have access
to such imaginative
as well where they can introspect where
they can analyze the consequences of
actions that they might want to take
yeah and that leads me back to this open
source nature of err sim why is open
source so important for this particular
platform and in research in general I'm
seeing it more and more we released our
sim as an open source platform in
February 2017 and one of the reasons for
making an open source is the fact that
what we're trying to accomplish with our
sim is of AI complete nature and let me
explain what do I mean by AI complete
nature what we're trying to do is we are
trying to create reality and you know to
create reality is to understand reality
so it's a seemingly impossible task that
a small group of people cannot
accomplish so we hope that by open
sourcing it we would excite you know
many researchers students developers you
know who want to participate and
contribute back to this project with
realistic model of vehicles sensors
agents environments so that we can
bootstrap and build something that we
individually ourselves couldn't build
and since open sourcing we have had an
active engagement with developers and
researchers all around the world with
many of them contributing in very
significant ways tell me how
collaboration happens in your world as
you can imagine our work is a very
interdisciplinary the team comprises of
roboticists
machine learning researchers developers
engineers pilots and the thing is when
you think about such an interesting
project you need to you know realize
that many of these collaborations have
happened very spontaneously like over
lunch or a coffee or tea it is clear to
all of us that given the ambitious
nature of some of these projects we need
to work together and we need to actively
go and seek out folks who are
accomplishing some things that can add
and complement to our research one of
the great thing about this place is that
there are hardly any boundaries and many
of our research projects
have been a result of an informal
hallway conversation or conversation
over lunch and we're pretty much we talk
about what we are doing and then an idea
collects and we go ahead and build it
[Music]
your background is really interesting
you're an AI researcher but you're also
a pilot and a flight instructor and
you've actually built an airplane
how did a VA ssin and machine learning
research come together in your life I
was always enamored by anything that
flies from a very young age and you know
computer science was important thing as
well growing up you study computer
science because growing up in India
there weren't many opportunities for
aviation but you know computer science
was an upcoming field and I was always
in love with algorithms and AI
specifically ended up coming to us and
did my PhD in machine learning once I
started working at Microsoft I realized
that it's time for me to go back and see
if there's something I could do in
aviation and you know Seattle is the
birthplace of aviation that's how I
think about it I got my private pilot's
license in 2009 and quickly realized the
potential of technology and specifically
the role of AI and ml that can possibly
change in the field of aviation in fact
you know beyond autonomous cars there is
so much discussion on autonomous flight
so autonomous personalized vehicles that
can possibly take you from here to see
Seattle downtown in less than 15 minutes
right and I mean to be honest the
technology is maturing very rapidly and
the way I think is that AI and ML are
going to be one of the critical
components to enable that so you know if
you think about self-driving car a self
flying car is even a hard thing to do
and consequently we need to make sure
that those vehicles are perfectly safe
and they would be pretty much piloted
via and AI and m/l systems it should be
as simple for anyone to go in a car put
an address and just relax and set and
that vehicle should go and drop you
there and in order to enable that
scenario ai and ML would be the coal
engine that would make this thing happen
this is what I had been thinking about
and through our informatics and robotics
a research program we have been trying
to answer some of these questions I
think we are
the cusp of technological breakthrough
in that space there's already you know
many efforts in the space they are
trying to accomplish it so you mentioned
the airplane that I built yeah right so
you know I ended up designing the
avionics system as well and it is
designed to run AI and m/l algorithms on
it it has sensing for other vehicles in
the vicinity it has onboard whether it
has an autopilot system that can
maneuver it not just horizontally but
also vertically but more importantly we
have the ability to interface that
airplane with a planning or a robotic
decision-making system that can guide
that airplane to fly you know
autonomously at least in the cruise
phase of flight so the way I see my
airplane the technologies are already
there if I could just solve landing and
takeoff that would be a flying car that
I would bet my life on that's the first
and last mile problem of tracking yes
our cars it's like it's just that last
bit where the tricky parts come in yes
exactly and I think those are the
hardest parts because now we are very
close to the ground in the vicinity of
population and other moving vehicles
yeah and we need to make sure we do a
better job in those spaces have you
flown the plane you built yeah yeah yeah
so I fly tested it I did the first
flight and probably it was the scariest
thing that I ever did but it also taught
me you know you pretty much build your
own airplane and then push it through
the certification as well as the flight
testing regime and it gives you a sense
of what it takes to build robust systems
I'd like to contrast the state of AI
systems to aviation systems say 100
years back it's pretty dangerous to fly
but as a race we not only enable that
technology but we came up with protocols
we came up with processes that took that
technology and matured the whole
technology and now you know we can do
things that possibly hundred years ago
we never would have imagined now and
that's what the state of a is it might
seem very scary there are a lot of
unknowns a lot of uncertainties but
there are a lot of positive benefits
the technology and I think together we
should strive to think about processes
and regulations so that we can start
using these technologies and beneficial
ways so that kind of leads into the
question I asked every researcher that
comes into the podcast booth is there
anything about your work that keeps you
up at night
in terms of you know possible downsides
or unintended consequences so when you
think about AI or machine learning
machine is intelligence technologies
there is a lot of skeptism
about you know potential negative
effects and a lot of this fear and
skepticism
I personally believe is coming because
of lack of proper understanding so as we
move forward we need to start debunking
some of the myths and education and
knowledge dissemination is one of the
ways to do that and this knowledge
dissemination needs to go all the way to
the lawmakers the regulator's so that
they can make better decisions you know
as I mentioned AI is a pretty powerful
technology you can utilize it to do
social good but you can also use it to
do harm you know it's the prospect of
doing harm that raises a lot of fears
and skeptism
in everyone's mind which might further
affect how laws and regulations are
being made yeah so right now we are
seeing that the advances in AI are
happening at a breakneck speed yeah
however many of these advances in order
to be realized in real world in order to
start affecting our lives yeah you know
we have to start thinking about
regulatory and the law aspects of it and
there is a chance that the regulation
and the lawmaking might lag the amount
of innovation that's happening in the
air space so consequently I worry about
that possibly you know regulations which
might be a knee-jerk reaction to certain
situations might lead to stifling of
innovation in our space and so
constantly thinking about mechanisms in
which we can keep innovating as well as
think about consequences in society so
that we can come up with laws and
regulations at the pace that can match
the innovations way as we finish up here
what do you see on the horizon in your
field and what are the big challenges
that we want the next generation of best
and brightest minds to be working on
what advice would you give to young
aspiring researchers who might want to
help tackle these problems one thing
that I encourage everyone who aspires to
work in this field is to actually think
about technology that would influence a
large amount of people in the world
right often you know the technological
innovations by the time they trickle
down to the masses it takes ages and
given the power of AI we want these
technologies to be effective as soon as
possible like you probably know for
instance from the farming perspective we
need to double the yield of our crops by
2050 without increase in arable land so
if we invest in air technologies that
can help solve that goal we can assure
that we will reach masses so I would
strongly encourage folks to think about
these problem areas where most of the
population of the world gets positively
influenced Ashish Kapoor's been
absolutely fascinating talking to you
today and I'm so grateful that you came
in and sat down in the podcast with us
thank you it's been wonderful funky it
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Rajesh Kapoor
and the machine learning approach to
building autonomous and robotic systems
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]